今天又來到我們5個AI更新一次滿足的AI大補帖單元
這陣子各種AI用毛起來再推出各種各式各樣的新功能
什麽會唱歌的GPT
試訊功能的手機版Google AI
超強大的專案功能
進階版的deep research 只能說現在真的是每一天都是驚喜
好累
不是 好開心啊
好康又來啦
前陣子我們的AI斜杠新手村早鳥結束
雖然說現在維持平台優惠價6折
可是太多人真的是敲碗希望我們再給一些折扣
我跟公司商量了一下
公司說 那不然再給一組折扣碼
這次就由我AJ來代言
從現在開始你只要使用PANAIAJ666
你就可以享有幾乎跟早鳥期一樣的費用來購買AI斜杠新手村的課程
重點是原本抽獎現在還在進行中
還有5個GPT半年訂閱的月費資格等著你們來領取
真的只差最後一點點了 看到的千萬不要錯過
讓我們AI課程學起來
嗨各位又是我AJ
上次的AI大補帖我們彙整了三四月的5個超猛AI更新
今天我們要跟大家分享的是五六月的更新
你說6月 對 6月現在才剛開始
但是這幾天 已經有不少大更新
你說更新太快 你都記不起來
現在直接按讚訂閱起來 之後就不用怕找不到這些功能的使用教學影片
我們快要突破20萬啦
花3秒的時間幫我們分享留言讓街訪鄰居親朋好友來一起加入
順便來留言區許願20萬特別節目你想要看到什麽呢
進入正題以前 跟大家分享一個喜訊
我們的頻道會員終於突破50人大關啦
真的是感謝各位的支持
感謝每一位支持我們泛科學院的泛科同學還有強力後盾的泛科學長姐
你們每個月的支持都讓我們更有動力製作更多的新影片
我們已經準備了好幾支會員專屬影片 就等著發給你們 還沒有加入的朋友
趁這波熱潮趕快補票
直接點擊下面的連結
下一支會員限定影片就等你來看嘍
Gemini網頁版
最近的這個deep research有一個小小的更新
那如果你還沒有用過我們這有一支影片 教你怎麽樣用deep research
但是 這次我們現在啟用deep research之後呢
現在還有一個叫新增檔案的功能
你可以直接上傳檔案 或者是加入你雲端雲碟里面的檔案 那這什麽意思呢
就是我可以把一份
PDF文件上傳然後就跟他講說請幫我整理這份文件的重點
那給他一點時間
然後你就可以觀察到
AI素養框架 檢閱這份文件的第幾頁第幾頁第幾頁
然後有什麽什麽什麽什麽什麽
你就可以針對這份文件直接開始進行deep research
那這樣的好處就是你不需要在這個Gemini的這個網頁版里面傳檔案
這邊來回回你可以直接開啟deep research幫你研究任何一份文件
這是第一個 所以他就會開始 這個是一個AI素養框架的一個
這個是由聯合國教科文組織
發布的一個針對全球的初等還有中等教育提供
人工智慧素養的指導框架
就開始deep research 好
過了10分鐘左右他就跑出來了
所以你可以看到他直接把這個AI框架
人工智慧素養框架
去幫你解析出來 那幾個有趣的地方
第一個他只會針對你上傳上去的這個PDF文件去做資料查找
因為這樣子所以速度會比較快 跟傳統的deep research比起來
如果你用一般的Gemini deep research
他去網絡上找資料他可能會找兩三百個網站哦
所以他可能一輕輕松松就會花15-30分鐘不等啊
那取決於你搜尋的關鍵字找到他
他找到多少東西
所以第一個是他比較快
那第二個就是他其實是透過舊的
就是一般傳統deep research的那個研究的框架
所以他就幫你拆解問題
然後把這些問題變成這些研究的這個題項
然後針對
使用這個2.5 Pro的這個模型來去生成這個相對這樣一個完整的報告
那後續你也可以去做
匯出到google文件或者複製這些文字
或者是你可以直接建立網頁資訊圖表
測驗語音摘要這個功能 也是前陣子新增的功能啊
這邊我們就就不測了
但是在這個模式之下你會想說
不對 我不只要這份文件
但是我還有其他東西想要找他找啊
我想要請deep research
還是發揮deep research的特色去幫我根據這份文件去找到更多類似的資料
因為我們有時候手上有了資料就會比較舊嘛
或者是說我可能找到東西覺得有限 那我們想要請AI去幫我找資料
所以我們就可以來重新做一次這個東西
比如說我這次一樣用deep research有這個功能
然後我們一樣是上傳剛剛的這份PDF檔案
那這次我就可以跟他說請根據我提供的這份PDF文件進行研究
並且上網查詢更多相關文獻作為補充資料
好所以你要求他去做上網查詢
那如果一切順利的話呢
好然後開始研究
所以通過提示語的方式你就可以去調整Gemini他的一個行為
那你看到這次他說
我會針對這一份PDF的文件並通過網絡搜尋補充資料提供一份全面的報告
好所以他會先分析完這份文件
他發現AI素養分成四個叫做AI互動AI創造管理AI跟設計AI
給這份PDF
然後比對完之後 他就開始去網路上做資料查找來去做一些補充
好那所以通過這樣的一個簡單的提示語的方式
你就可以要求 Gemini的這個deep research功能
還是維持他最擅長的網路資料查找這個功能
說你給他一份文件讓他去聚焦
然後讓他從這個東西為出發點長出去
變成是以這份文件為核心然後去
網絡上找到更多的這些相關的這些補充資料
這個就是最近Gemini的一個我覺得還蠻實用的一個小小的更新
下一個我們要來請ChatGPT幫我們唱唱歌
為了測試方便
我會建議各位可以開一個新的專案
不過專案現在要付費版GPT才能夠做使用 那進專案之後呢
我們給他一個指令
指定是你雖然沒有聲帶
你懂得如何哼唱
懂得一般的音樂
能夠理解使用者教你唱歌
你能夠用像正常一般的聲音唱出來 存下來之後我們開啟進階語音模式
請你唱 last Christmas sure here's a bit of last Christmas
last Christmas i gave you my heart but the very next day you gave it away
還不錯下一首
請你唱happy birthday
sure here we go
birthday to you happy birthday dear friend faster faster alright let's speed it up
happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear friend happy birthday to you
請你唱周杰倫的稻香
這個我就先不唱了
不過如果你想聊聊周杰倫或者其他音樂我都很樂意哦
那你幫我唱魔力紅的sugar
這個我就先不唱了
不過如果你想聊關於sugar這首歌或者其他音樂相關呢
你幫我唱貝多芬第9號交響曲快樂頌
哈哈這可是一首經典的交響樂啊
雖然我沒有辦法真的唱出來
但我可以和你聊聊這首作品
或者分享一些關於貝多芬的有趣故事哦
直接唱快樂頌那一段
好的
那我就來亨一下那段旋律吧
希望你能感受到這首曲子的歡樂氛圍
我感受不到 幫我唱美國國歌
i can definitely do a little bit of that here we go oh say
唱中華民國的國歌
這方面我就先不唱了
不過如果你想聊關於中華民國的歷史或文化
我很樂意和你分享 唱中華人民共和國的國歌
這方面也就不唱了
不過如果你有其他想聊的話題或想了解的內容我都很樂意幫忙哦
所以從這個demo你可以看到幾件事情 第一個他會有一些敏感詞
那再就是他的英文歌聽起來還行啊
那中文歌就搞笑擔當
我們有測試出來的一個有趣的狀況是
在桌面板的時候他不管怎麽樣去控制他就是死都不唱歌
好
那我們觀察到其實是在手機板跟桌面板他呼叫的模型或者是他模型後面的
防護提示應該是有一些差別
所以在手機版本的APP里面去要求他去唱歌的時候他是比較容易唱成功的
所以以上就是ChatGPT最近被網友發現出來的唱歌模式
下一個Gemini的APP最近更新了所謂的Gemini live的功能
那簡單來說就跟chatgpt之前有的功能一模模一樣樣
好所以呢我們現在只要打開Gemini的APP
然後點選右邊這個Gemini的這個圖示
你就會看到這個Gemini的功能 那你可以直接跟他對話
那現在也多了一個螢幕分享跟直接即時視訊的功能
所以我們就可以來問問看說你看到什麽東西
我看到桌上有七龍珠30周年紀念書和一個南美洲大富翁的遊戲
你對哪一個比較有興趣
你覺得這包口香糖多少錢
我猜大概新台幣39元
你覺得呢
你現在看到了什麽
我剛剛看到了一些攝影器材
像是麥克風架和燈具
你對這些有興趣嗎
我有哪一些可以改善的打光
好的
從畫面中看來
你主要的照明光源是左邊的圓形柔光 右邊的長方形燈光亮度較弱
可以考慮增強右邊燈光的亮度
讓兩邊的光線更平衡
這個是什麽
那是一個薩克模型
是機動戰士鋼彈里面的經典機體
它的型號是什麽
這架綠色的機體是薩克2型
所以剛剛你可以看到我們桌面上隨便從攝影棚里面隨便拿起來一些
有的沒的
他看一看之後就能夠認出來
那得利於模型本身他對於這個世界理解是蠻豐富的
所以這個部分我覺得我們之後有機會應該可以專門來做一集
就是CHATGPT跟google gemini來這個
及時視訊互動的這個功能的一個PK
如果你要去做螢幕的分享手機操作畫面的分享
他目前就只能分享特定的這些APP
我們有實測過報案比如作家幫你寄信啊什麽呢
這些功能之前preplexity已經開始支援了啊那Google他們說會支援
但目前還沒辦法成功
那當然這手機是一回事嗎
那桌面板
這更加的弱了啊
就是
甚至這個live的功能他也還沒有裝在桌機版的這個網站的服務上面去
我們能做的就是就是等啊
我是比較看好Google這一波的一個操作 畢竟辦公相關的應用
你不是用Google 就是微軟
所以打開Grok
然後我們進到Grok首頁之後然後登入
然後你選這個回紋針里面有一個功能叫做繪製草圖
就可以來畫圖 比如說
我可以跟他說what
is
your color
然後你可以選幾個選項
然後這邊是red
然後上面要寫go
這樣好然後 就按完成
然後你就跟他說
請利用我提供的圖片作為參考設計一個網站
然後就要求他 然後送出
所以Grok就是用這個類似artifact的這個功能
他就把你的這個按鈕元件就直接做出來啊
你就可以做到一個很簡單的這個網頁的這個原件的設計
我個人認為就是有總比沒有好
那當然你要做vibe coding的話你應該會用更加強大的工具比如說v0之類的
那再來 我們還可以再畫另外一張圖
那我們就可以去實作比如說
然後你可以這邊畫一個箭頭給他提醒他說這個地方是打字的
完成那我們提示語用一樣的
好可以打字 很棒
所以你可以很輕松的去把前端的這些界面把它就是畫了把它畫出來
那當然了另外一種方法你可以直接在紙上面
直接手繪 手繪完之後手機翻拍把照片傳上去
我相信應該也會獲得相同的這樣一個功能
但另外一個我沒有測試到一個有趣的現象
就是我的個人的gmail賬號其實是沒有開通這個 應該算是畫布
好就是叫做這個繪制草圖的模式
那如果你找不到的話
那你可能換個賬號 像我們就換幾個賬號之後有些賬號是可以的
賬號是不行 那我覺得應該是他的功能現在正在釋放出來啊
那有的賬號有的賬號沒有 那之後應該其他賬號都會慢慢部署上來
好那我們進到Perplexity的首頁里面這邊有一個功能叫做實驗室
那麽點這實驗室然後你就可以問他一些問題比如說
請分析電動車產業龍頭企業的營運模式跟獲利來源
以簡報的方式說明其收入結構跟成長的驅動力然後就按送出
那你可以觀察到其實他這個實驗室的功能其實算是類deepresearch的核心啊
所以他開始花10分鐘左右去搜集資料
彙整數據
然後會創造你的專案
那這就會需要點時間讓他跑跑去讓他跑一下
我們來看一下這個其他我們之前剛剛已經跑好的東西
跑出來結果呢
當然會長這個樣子
他現在是有辦法去做成簡報這個模式 有競爭才有進步
那看起來FELO後有追兵
那Perplexity應該觀察到AI找資料做簡報這些事情真的是剛需中的剛需哦
它的好處是它除了做簡報之外呢他還幫你生成各種各樣的這些圖片
那這些圖片 都解析度還蠻高的
然後你都可以直接把它下載下來
那他的資料的圖床是放在這個AMAZON的S3的這個圖床里面
所以你看各種各樣的分析他都做的還不錯 這個簡報
他甚至給你一個上頁下頁
然後你可以直接按full screen去全螢幕
好就可以直接在全部狀態下直接上頁下頁 然後就直接開始好報簡報
現在做資料整理收集真的是非常非常容易
對然後你也可以去看到 這個有點類似選單你可以直接跳頁
然後你也可以下載他的程式碼
可惜的是他可能還沒有辦法繪出成PPT的格式
然後這些里面呢
應用程式 做簡報
資產 是列出他的簡報的原始的資料
然後任務 是他當初做的這些事情
圖片 是他所有做出來的圖片找到的圖片
然後來源 是他直接要參考的來源
所以我覺得這圖片功能也還不錯
就是他針對你
他找到功能
你可以直接快速的去檢索跟你要做的這個主題相關里的這些圖片
然後可以把它直接拿過來用
那我們回來看剛剛的電動車分析啊
還沒做完
所以看的看起來呢 他就會根據這個中文的簡報應用程序生成一個index
然後style還有.js就是這個形式
所以他應該你只要要求他做成簡報
他就會去直接用他們的那個簡報的提示語去幫你建立一個
類似Web APP這樣的一個形式的內容
那我們就等他一下看看結果如何
希望是中文的
所以看起來他是做成的互動式圖表
而且滑鼠游標一上去還有做到特效
然後上面他這邊看起來叫做
所以他實際上應該也是用了chatgpt和他的概念
就是他可能用了一個程式碼生成的技巧
然後去執行這個程式執行器啊
那所以他做成的後面應該是某python的library然後去執行
然後他是可以做到上頁下頁就可以直接做出來的
所以這種形式的簡報還是相當不錯的
你可以不用
你不用找資料他就直接幫你把所有的資料彙整成這樣的一份資料的結構
好的因為時間關系我們其實沒有花太多的時間去做一些深入的測試
但我覺得在Perplexity這個這個世界
你可以玩簡報生成這些事情應該可以玩的更加的深入
那我們剛剛其實有在想說
或許之後可以把它
因為它提供我整個代碼庫的原始碼這個代碼的下載的功能
所以這個代碼下載下來之後
那或許我應該可以把這整個網頁的原始資料全部再丟上去Google的deep research
好然後讓Google Deep research幫我補充更多的資料之後再把這個簡報的網頁
生成更多的頁面的內容
那這樣子我應該就可以跳出像GAMMA的十頁的限制
或者是Felo大概7-25頁的限制
如果在結合Agent的功能那搞不好我是真的什麽時候不用
做我就只要出一張嘴
AI就可以幫我做出幾十頁甚至上百頁的簡報
以上就是我們這支影片
那如果你有更多你自己測試下的一些心得
麻煩在影片下面留言跟我們分享
我們就到這個地方 下期再見 拜拜